it is friday night baseball it
is the start of the freeway series 2021
and the angels looking to try and pay
back the dodgers who swept
all six games of the freeway series a
year ago
on the mount for the angels tonight 24
year old right-hander griffin cannon
coming off a good one saturday at
seattle
in fact it was that start that got the
month of may off to a good start for the
angels they haven't won since it was a
breezy win for him
against the m's up in the pacific
northwest went into the sixth inning
allowed one earned run
struck out nine had plenty of offensive
support in a 10-5
victory dodgers hitting with runners in
scoring position during this
long drought has been dreadful pick off
toss to his second and they pick off the
runner
caught trying to get back is seeger
cannon is a goal glover and he
wheeled around in fire to strike the
second leo
since the start of last season 21
consecutive outings without a loss so
two gun bases empty now for mike trout
he's struck out in five of his last
seven abs
in the race series he swings and pops it
up behind second base
retreating in short center field and
battling a bit of a breeze gavin lux
makes the catch
and the inning is over now runs though
hits no errors and nobody left well
let's see what the dodgers can do with
second and third
and one out matt beatty grounds the
first one that he sees
into the shift that'll bring him to man
from third but down just have the game's
first ride
will smith scores and a man baby grind
out and it's well nothing dodgers
curious has a one-to-nothing lead to
play with upton back in the
lineup for the angels he had missed the
last couple of ball games
often sends the ball to left center
field that one's well hit and gone
get on up welcome back
justin upton it's a 1-1 ball game
upton first game back after missing the
final two against the rays
jumped on that pitch he's back and
that's home run number
six of the year for him that will tie up
the game at one
here's taylor ward at the plate he's
looking for his first hit this season
with the angels and
swings it down and lifts the ball high
and hits it well out into left center
field
it's out of here taylor ward's first hit
of the year
is a solo shot that gives the angels
their first lead of the night
taylor ward fastball hunting gets it
right down the middle of the plate
94. we talked about maurice is a guy
that is going to be around the strike
zone you know that going into it
and you just look for something
aggressive right out of the gate he gets
that fastball this fastball is up in the
zone
taylor full extension second and third
two out top of the order david fletcher
the seventh angel to hit their frame
and fletch has a base hit that's gonna
bring in rojas easily
here's butera without a throw
a four-run second
and flat so good with runners in the
scoring position your worst nightmare is
a pitcher because he's so difficult to
strike out he's going to put in play
puts head into the left center driving
in two nice swing by drew guterre
getting his first at battening the
double
now scores a run fletch doing what he
does best
a lead off hit for iglesias taylor ward
coming up
by ball to right slicing toward the
corner mookie betts tracks it down
two steps from the wall on the warning
track
ward flies to deep right bets makes the
play
first down to the bottom of the four i
think lucky may have been
looking to where that fence was because
that ball got on him the last five feet
in a hurry looked a little surprised
canning's gonna have to fade a tough out
with runners in scoring position because
justin turner last year hit
350 in spots like this bounced on the
left side fair ball fielded by rojas
long throw right on the money and the
inning is over
they leave them at second and third
dodgers have stranded
five one out single for the angel shohei
ohtani will be the batter
shohei hits it in the air into left
center field that ball is carrying over
the head of the left fielder pollock
ball is out on the warning track being
waved around is fletcher he will score
from first
[Music]
and the angels lead rose it's now 5-1
great power the other way against a
tough tough lefties luffy's hitting
187 against him this year shohei
going the other way fastball 94
brings his hands up and that's a rocket
the other way
and he is amazing griffin canning ready
to work we hit to the sixth inning
angels have a
5-1 lead retired as muncie there's one
away
has had a couple middle middle fastballs
and pop both up
over the shoulder watch right
that's a play as an outfielder coming in
much easier than an infielder going back
on the ball
so a one-out runner in scoring position
now for chris taylor taylor
sends it on the ground to rojas who
knocks it down
he won't have a play and taylor's safe
at first
first and second now with one gun so
after the pop-up that started the inning
you get a miss play in right and then an
error
on the third baseman jose rojas and it's
a little tempest in a teapot brewing now
for aj pollock
that is a called third strike
got him looking after all that finally a
pitch call to strike
and that is out number two pinch hit
here with the
lefty on the mound and sheldon noisy
is going to be the pinch hitter lifted
in the air into right field
should be the final out taylor ward is
back shy of the rim of the track he'll
gather that one in
and that is how the inning will end so
they end up leaving runners at
second and third so stepping up to the
plate for the angels is jose rojas
still looking for his first big league
run batted in that's with the runner at
second
into the opposite field and that one
gets down and
away from aj [ __ ] iglesias scores
rojas into second again and there's that
first
rbi there's a halo in the big leagues
for jose rojas what a game
so two gun now for the top of the order
and david fletcher has had a nice night
already with a couple of hits and two
runs batted in
that's into right field and that's down
for another knock for david fletcher
rojas scores what do you say about
sneaky fletch he sneaks out within on
the line for a double another
rbi for fletch seven runs on 11 hits
here's ohtani once more he has doubled
in a run tonight
ohtani to right field betts gives it a
look and it's off the road
goodness is he strong he was added
forward that pitch
man he is showtime all the time
ohtani that's off the end of the back
one-handed
kind of a rocky one here for joe kelly
in his first outing of the year now he's
got to deal with trout
trout with a little shot in the left
field that's going to drop in and now
bounce away from pollock he just gave up
on the ball
and mike trout's easily going to get the
third ohtani has already scored
and the angels now lead it 9-1
now paula is limping trying to slam on
the brakes to go back
and get the ball and the brakes don't
function
it's going to be a triple for mike trout
and
that's going to be all for aj pollock
tonight cookies reached twice tonight he
doubled
[Music]
[Applause]
fourth home run of the season for milky
bucks and a 9-2
game and that should wrap it up tonight
the angels bats come alive a big
offensive
night a great start by griffin canning
and the five-game losing streak
is a thing of the past